not taking it very seriously as Fox News
yesterday I had video view of
congressman Devin Nunez suggesting that
the corona virus pandemic is a great
time to go to restaurants because they
won't be busy you'll be able to get
right in and get yourself a beautiful
table we now have video of the buffoons
at Fox & Friends which Trump watches
remember saying this is a great time to
fly despite warnings from every public
health organization in the world saying
the opposite first reminder this was
Devin Nunez we played this clip for you
yesterday and there's a lot of concerns
with the economy here because people are
scared to go out but I will just say one
of the things you can do if you're
healthy you and your family it's a great
time to just go out go to a local
restaurant
yeah likely you can get in get in easily
there's you know let's not hurt the
working people in this country that are
relying on wages and tips to keep their
small business run do that don't run to
the I understood I just don't run to the
grocery store and buy you know four
thousand dollars of food you know go to
your local local park very sympathetic
to what's going on okay so now let's get
to Fox and Friends
here's Ainsley Earhardt on Fox and
Friends it's actually the safest time to
fly everyone I know that's flying right
now terminals are pretty much dead ghost
towns and then the planes remember back
in the day when you had a seat next to
you possibly empty you could stretch out
a little more it's like that on every
flight now what what do you mean when I
used to fly years ago right
my wife was flying yesterday every seat
on the plane was taken really absolutely
and bacon was taken there were people
leaving New York to head down to Florida
what wouldn't you yesterday the mayor
declared a state of emergency here so
there it is great time to fly and notice
Steve Doocy adding idiocy to idiocy
saying we have a state of emergency here
in New York why not go down to Florida
spread germs on the plane and then
spread them in Florida where they didn't
at least as of then have a state of
emergency
untrue at this point what's going on in
Florida people congregating at beaches
people go into concerts people go into
bars restaurants spreading spreading
spreading Florida increasingly a cluster
of coronavirus infection irresponsible
people and remembered that fox news's
own audience skews older is it a good
strategy to suggest your audience behave
in a way that will kill them off and
thus hurt your ratings I mean I this is
obviously it's all immoral and unethical
and wrong what they're doing but even
from a business strategy does this make
sense make it likely that the people
watching you will be more likely to die
if they follow your recommendations and
I really hope that Donald Trump
yesterday during his press conference
admitting that coronavirus is not under
control that we are possibly in a
recession that people need to stay home
I hope that this is going to make an
impact because too many Republican
governors plus the clowns at Fox News
plus Rush Limbaugh plus the rest of them
they've been almost urging people to
ignore the recommendations from doctors
and public health officials and pandemic
infection outbreak experts those are the
people we should be listening to
not Ainsley Earhardt and Steve douchey
these people are dangerous this is not a
joke this business plan of theirs will
kill their own viewers but this is a
sort of negligence at a mass scale I
don't know how this can be called news
of any kind and of course there is no
distinction on Fox News between news and
opinion and in reality they claim
there's a distinction and you have
people who are not only a particular
risk if they do this and they fly and
they go to the beach and they go to
restaurants and do all this stuff it's
not just that there are people because
of both ignorance in our country Fox
News not distinguishing between news and
opinion and the fact that people can't
tell the difference between news news
and opinion in many cases you have
people who think that that's news they
see they see Ainsley Earhardt saying
it's so convenient to fly right now
they consider that equivalent to a
doctor specializing in infections saying
something different it's equivalent
because of lack of media literacy
because of Fox News deliberately
blurring the difference between their
news and opinion it's kind of all
infected with with opinion anyway as we
know
simply because of the ignorance that is
so widespread in this country the
reporting about coronavirus on fox news
has been and continues to be a public
health hazard and we're going to have
more clips on the shows Instagram page I
encourage you to follow us there at
David Pakman show oh and also I posted
my work from home set up yesterday to my
instagram david pakman follow me check
it out let me know what you're doing if
you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time favorite apps called blinka
stinketh lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
non-fiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video